>> Congratulations on finishing Lesson four. In this lesson,
we learned how to explore the relationship between two variables.
Our main visualization tool, was the scatter plot. But we
also augmented the scatter plot, with conditional summaries, like means.
>> We also learned about the
benefits and the limitations of using correlation.
To understand the relationship between two variables
and how correlation may effect your decisions
over which variables to include in your final models.
>> As usual, another important part of this lesson was learning how to
make sense of data through adjusting
our visualizations. We learned not to necessarily
trust our interpretation of initial scatter
plots like with the seasonal temperature data.
And we learned how to use jitter and transparency to reduce over plotting.
>> We'd love to hear your thoughts in the discussion forum and we
hope you learned a lot. Next, we'll move
onto lesson five, where we talk about multivariate analysis.